بعد أيام قليلة من إعلان الولايات المتحدة
عن
عقوبات مالية
وقيود على التأشيرات على
المسؤولين الإثيوبيين والإريتريين الذين
يقولون إنهم يعتقدون أنهم متواطئون
في الانتهاكات في منطقة تيغراي الإثيوبية ،
تم إرسال
هذا الفيديو الذي تم تصويره سراً بنزاهة في شيريتاون ،
وهو يظهر
الآباء اليائسين مجتمعين في مكاتب الأمم المتحدة
في  شيري
يائسًا لسماع أقوال
أحبائهم الذين يقولون إن الجنود
الإثيوبيين
والإريتريين أخذوهم قسرًا واحتجزوا
وضُربوا.
بالدعوة إلى
الإفراج الفوري
عن هؤلاء الشباب ، شاركنا أيضًا
النتائج التي توصلنا إليها مع مبعوث رئيس مجلس الشيوخ كريس كونز ،
بايدن إلى إثيوبيا ،
وهو
يدعو أيضًا إلى الإفراج الفوري
عن هؤلاء الشباب قائلاً
إنه في حالة تعرضهم للأذى أو إذا لم يتم
إطلاق سراحهم  ثم يجب أن يكون هناك
مساءلة ج  ن ن
لندن